hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and today we have a little bit of an
interesting weapon to talk about as one
of the legendaries in Borderlands 3 this
is always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe Rafi knew and let's get
started
as always spoilers just in case I will
be showing some additional planets been
way through the game so if you don't
want to see any of that just be aware
there really isn't crazy stuff I do only
show one boss but if you are at this
current planet then you are do you know
who the boss is other or not you're
really not missing much of no worries
there but yeah I found this weapon while
actually farming one of the ending
things the proving grounds as they're
called if anybody doesn't know proving
grounds are stuff at the very end of the
game they had they're kind of like could
think of it like big dungeons or big
raids I'm not gonna give away exactly
what's in them and specifically and all
the creepy stuff that's involved with it
but there is it like I think six of them
at the end of the game that you can do
and ended up grabbing this weapon from
one of those and is called the handsome
jackhammer currently at level 50 it the
one that I got which is the highest rank
of course my damage is 544 with 52
accuracy 67 handling a reload time of
1.5 fire rate is nine point three seven
per second with a thirty-five magazine
size and it says everyone thinks there
that they are the hero of their own
story this is kind of a reference to
handsome jack always thinking he's the
hero when were the enemy so that's kind
of nice there and as 10% critical hit
damage at 44% weapon shield capacity 50%
reload speed and two time 2.2 times
weapon zoom now this is actually one of
the weirder weapons in the game because
I think this is the only weapon if not
one of the only weapon you know one of
the few weapons in the game that is
actually a hybrid of two manufacturers
now it doesn't state particularly that
it actually has two manufacturers but it
is a Hyperion weapon because obviously
it's handsome Jack's SMG it has to be
Hyperion seeing as he was the CEO of
Hyperion and but it also has a little
bit of touch of TD or because the bottom
little skill here is as thrown weapons
explode and bounce on impact now it
doesn't state specifically that it is a
TD or Hyperion hybrid but on
I think we can confer that because
obviously as soon as you throw this
weapon you'll see as soon as you reload
it you throw it just like every TD or
gun in the game so honestly I'm thinking
it's got a little bit of hint of TD or
and hyperion this could be because maybe
at one point you know handsome Jack was
going by being the CEO of Hyperion and
killing a bunch of different fat
manufacturers that he was you know in
the mood to fight with you know how like
how Molly Wan and outlets are kind of
squaring up in this game I have a
feeling that Hyperion was probably like
[ __ ] it let's go raid TD or because
honestly from what I've just been
getting from this game they're like the
biggest pushover company out of all the
other companies like everyone has this
weird thing with them and are like yeah
[ __ ] TD or they're absolutely terrible
weapons and everybody is better than
them so they're kind of like the
punching bag of the manufacturers so
they probably raided on got him to make
them a weapon or maybe did something
like that and then and then Hyperion
kind of switched up the schematics to
make it theirs and boom we have the
Hyperion TD or type hybrid obviously
there's probably no way to confirm nor
deny if anything I just said in the past
two minutes is actually true but that's
just my opinion I actually don't really
mind the TD or version sometimes some of
the TDR weapons are pretty shitty with
some of the things they do but this one
isn't too bad like it said like I said
it is when you throw the weapon it
explodes and bounces on impact and you
can actually see the bounce happen
because it's very apparent because it's
this white little aura that comes up
every time they bounce and it actually
does a pretty decent amount of damage
you'll see me here fighting Tron and to
be fair I was using the Khazar grenades
which I mean like are an average grenade
they aren't too crazy and high damage
but it's a it's your standard kazar
grenade absolutely smoking anything with
a shield so after the show went down I
decided to only throw the handsome
jackhammer to see if it was gonna work
and honestly every time you can see the
health skip is when those bounces hit in
so honestly that was a lot of damage
that happened to Tron and he got
completely [ __ ] up for me one thing I
also noticed about this weapon is that
regardless of whatever
of armor shield whatever this thing just
[ __ ] tears through it I was thinking
okay maybe this will be pretty good on
health you know there really isn't no an
element to this and might just be good
for standard health enemies so I but I
tried to do it anyway
I shot enemies that had shields their
health got torn up
I should enemies will arm where they
were getting torn up basically
practically anything that they had armor
shield regular health this weapon was
tearing through that so honestly if you
need some type of non elemental weapon
if you're having an elemental bill there
you just need a decent SMG this is
probably the one to do it and it doesn't
really happen all the time and when it
does happen it's a very faint and the
only problem is that it might be hard to
hear because the bounces it happens
roughly when he starts exploding and
bouncing on the weapon but with the
handsome jackhammer I believe if I am
correct you could actually hear handsome
Jack say a couple quotes while he's
shooting people banging around and then
he starts talking or only when he's
shooting like only when the gun is
shooting people or only when the gun and
kill something but I swear I heard
handsome Jack's voice when playing I
might be going crazy but I'm fairly
certain he is so if that is the case it
is a talking dual manufacturer legendary
SMG which is a giant word and I think
that's [ __ ] sick yeah let me know in
the comments down below what you guys
think about this weapon in terms of me
farming this I just got this strictly
from getting a lot of legendary loop you
can of course do legendary tink loop
farms like a lot of people have been
covering or if you have any other bosses
or maybe any other mini bosses that
you've got this weapon from different
let me know in the comments below so
that if people don't want to just have
the general loophole and then want to
start farming from a specific boss they
can do that too just to let you guys
know that if you do want to try to farm
this stuff reject the comments below
just in case be I'd like to be if you do
enjoy guys subscribed if you're new
looking for some of the support on the
borderlands videos especially the first
one that was really cool to see all that
but yeah thing guys so much it's always
like to be if you do enjoy a subscriber
free new like I said as I guys take care
have a great astir day and peace out
[Music]